Look out, Sony.
Hawkeye is taking aim at you — and he never
misses.
On August 20, Hollywood was rocked when reports
surfaced that Sony and Disney couldn't come
to terms on a new agreement to keep Tom Holland's
Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"Thank you, Mr. Stark.
But I'm...
I'm good."
"You're good?
How are you good?"
Unless the circumstances change dramatically,
it looks like the 23-year-old Holland is done
showing up in MCU movies after five appearances
over the past three years, beginning with
2016's Captain America: Civil War and ending
with 2019's Spider-Man: Far From Home.
The vast majority of people involved — including
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige and Holland
himself — have kept quiet so far on the
bombshell news, but one of the Avengers has
spoken out.
Jeremy Renner has played Clint Barton, also
known as Hawkeye, in the MCU for eight years
since first appearing in 2011's Thor, took
to Instagram on August 21 to vent his feelings
on the controversial subject.
He uploaded a still of himself in Avengers:
Endgame with a caption that reads,
"Hey @sonypictures we want Spider-Man back
to @therealstanlee and @marvel please, thank
you #congrats #spidermanrocks #🏹#please."
Poor grammar and odd hashtagging aside, it's
clear that Renner is clamoring for a new Spidey
deal, and that he falls on the Disney side
of the dividing line.
Renner has many irons in the fire — including
starring in major Hollywood films, launching
a musical career, and appearing in some slightly
strange Jeep commercials — but it's obvious
that Disney and Marvel offer the actor his
steadiest gig.
The man knows how hard it can be to find work
in Hollywood, having been a makeup artist
early in his career to make ends meet at a
time where he couldn't find casting anywhere.
Thankfully, Renner's place in the MCU is locked
tight, as he's slated to star on the upcoming
Marvel series Hawkeye set for release on the
Disney+ streaming service sometime
in the future.
Some might say it's smart of Renner to not
look a gift horse in the mouth and instead
come to Disney's defense after Sony has put
the blame on the House of Mouse.
But it's also possible that he just really
likes the new Spider-Man movies, and doesn't
want to deal with a disaster like The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 again.
"Too bad about that Spider-Guy.
Too bad he's disappeared.
Seems like everybody really needs him."
After the events of Avengers: Endgame and
Spider-Man: Far From Home, the web-slinger
seemed poised to take on a central role in
the MCU by continuing Tony Stark's legacy
and keeping the memory of his late mentor
alive.
Unfortunately, placing Peter Parker at the
center of the MCU may have been a misstep
on the part of Marvel's Feige, as it arguably
puts Disney at a distinct disadvantage in
negotiations with Sony.
With Sony having the sole film rights to Spider-Man
— rights the company has held since 1999,
when Marvel was holding a licensing fire sale
to stave off bankruptcy — Disney was already
on the wrong side of the corporate power-struggle.
Setting Spider-Man up to become an Avenger
and a key cog in the future of the franchise
may have only made matters worse.
Now they've set up a story that may well be
unfinished, depending on how things shake
out.
Hopefully Renner's plea for help is the first
of many public comments by Marvel-related
figures on the Marvel-Sony split; after all,
this is the social media age where everyone
and their mother lets loose their every thought
online.
The major players have been decidedly quiet
on the subject thus far, though fans are surely
waiting with bated breath to hear what Tom
Holland himself has to say.
It would also be very interesting to hear
what Marvel head honcho Feige has to say after
having Spider-Man ripped from his future MCU
plans after righting the ship for Sony in
the first place.
For now, Marvelites will have to be happy
with Hawkeye taking his aim and shooting his
shot.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.